Such a long string of numbers that I
think it's enough to label every atom in
the universe or something that. This
one was very big numbers
at least in computer terms... probably physicists might disagree
the IP is the Internet Protocol
an IP number is... they are used as addresses. So these are used to let you get data
to a particular place, to a particular
machine. That's the function of the IP address
IP addresses, in particular I'll do examples of IPv4, so this is the kind of "current internet"
It's called "Version 4"... I don't think versions 1 to 3 were ever
really deployed. It's been "Version 4"
since the seventies.
So the sort of examples you might see this kind of thing:
128 . 243 . 35 . 9
so at one point that was the IP address of one of my computers here, I don't think it is currently
This is an IP address in
what's called dotted quad notation so
you've got dots and you've got four
bytes. Each of these numbers here will
be less or equal to 255. 255 is the
biggest decimal number you can represent in a single
byte. You have this dotted quote notation
and that will get turned into in my PE
pocket into just a series of bits
ok so i'm not going to try to do the
binary or in my head but it's going to
be something I think that everybody will
be kind of a hundred 2843 similarly your
way through 29 which would be 1001 ok so
that's just gonna be this sequence of
bits is your IP address 94 address by
putting that sequence of bits in the
right place at the start of your packet
is going to get treated as a destination
address all the rout is on the path you
imagine the internet is a sequence of
Reuters that are all connected in some
means like this then if your packet
comes in here and its trying to get to
some guy out here it's going to get to
this route here and not reaching out to
make a decision which way to send it and
it's going to do that using the longest
prefix match on the destination address
look it up in the table and decide
should send it out of you know interface
a winter baby so the route is going to
receive your data they're going to pull
off whatever the stuff on the front
fitment
heads and so on might be they're going
to get an IP packet which is gonna have
might be having some data following it
and the head are they going to go look
at a particular location had see this
sequence of bits then they're gonna look
that sequence of bits of in the table
the entry that matches the best match
they can find ahsoka longest prefix
match so the longest sequence from the
start or way back that just matches
exactly those bits will . a particular
entry in the table and that entry in the
table will say which network interfaces
should transmit are usually so he
decides what these things are so these
numbers get assigned hierarchically so
there's a body call Diana the internet
assigned numbers Authority I think I got
that right
but baby this is a body which has
administrative control over all these
numbers it will hand them out to the
regional authorities there might be one
for Europe like 14 age-specific might
want for north america and those bodies
will have the Mountie perhaps national
authorities so might have actually UK
mind to united states is on and so this
prefix here which was your first the
first 16 bits has been handed out the
University not here so universally our
computers will typically be I don't know
we have all the prefixes but certainly
many will be within that prefix so that
means that any packet on the internet
that has that prefix at the beginning of
an address in the destination address
field but eventually when its way
towards our computer gotta get there are
a lot more computers in the world that
can deal with surely there are now tazia
activated when so many for ya
now there are just one of the reasons
ipv6 was perceived as having a great
benefit just the amount of addresses in
it so ipv6 instead of being 32 bits so
full of ice is under 28 it's so it's
just much bigger dresses 228 a very
large number
police in computer terms and one of the
reasons ipv6 to the long time to kind of
take off was that essentially is quite
the cost implications because you have
to upgrade the software in some cases
probably the hardliners and results of
lots of the Reuters that live inside
these networks and you had to get
software installed on you gotta get your
home route is able to school this stuff
you gotta get all the software stacks
network
protocol stacks on your devices to
support this stuff so windows have to be
updated to support ipv6 example it has
done for some time there but that was a
process that had to go from there was a
new piece of software implementation
that you have to get right contested I
kind of stuff bunch of services that
need to be upgraded to support ipv6 so
for example the name translation service
dns is the protocol that you translate
google com name into the IP address when
that was designed developed ipv4 with
everything the only IP going and so that
whole DNS infrastructure have to be
upgraded and updated to support this new
protocol so there's quite a lot of sort
of not on effects of playfulness it's
not as simple as just saying what will
have more bits of the address multiple
into that integrated services that have
to also support that and I think the
amount of complexity that was there
perhaps was surprising how expensive it
was to go through that process
it took longer to get ipv6 deployment
expected the like I'm Andy that's still
kind of going on although it is starting
to see significant deployment their
people have to come up with all the way
to deal about when you got too many
machines and not enough addresses this
is so that's where you get that data
network address translation we don't
have enough addresses to record every
machine so what we can do is we can kind
of faith in there